I just challenged you quickly didn't you
say that there would be none of this
without women having children you said
that yeah but um what I'm trying to say
is I don't like the fact that there's a
lot of men who have this mentality
towards women I don't see your value as
a woman outside of Let Me Marry You Let
Me breed you like a [__] like a [__]
cow and then you know like you're gonna
stay there I'm gonna do what I need to
do and all your whole purpose in your
whole existence is to do nothing but
have my kids
why is that a bad thing
that's what I look at look at that's
what my grandma did she had nine kids
and now she has over 50 grandkids and I
feel like your track you're making it
seem more terrible
motherhood to being a cow you just
compared motherhood to breeding being
bred like a cat comparing like